Welcome to ICT for Dummies Episode 7
Liquidity Part 2
Highest Probability Liquidity Pools
Yo yo, check it, we gon' do this session
I don't even want to go back to my brethrens, listen
We going to the Probability Liquidity Pools
Don't be asking me where I'm going because I'm gonna do
Liquidity
She wanna be with me
Alright yo, cut this shit right now
Stop it!
Liquidity Part 2, Highest Probability Liquidity Pools
Today we're going to be going over all the different types of liquidity pool
In the first liquidity video we went over the basic bi-side liquidity and cell-side liquidity
Which is essentially the foundation of liquidity
But there is way more to that than just bi-side liquidity and cell-side liquidity
So hopefully you can learn something new with this video
And show you how to truly identify the different types of liquidity
Whether it is time liquidity, whether it is internal liquidity, whether it is external liquidity
There's a whole lot of it
Whether it's your mom's liquidity, I'm just kidding
Anyways, so let's start off pretty simple here
Alright guys, the first type of liquidity that we're going to go over is session liquidity
Why is this important?
It's because price often reacts very strongly to previous session highs and lows
This is where the major high and major lows are going to be of each session
For example, on the left side here you can see we have Asian session
So you have the entire Asia session and you can see here's the major high
And here's the major low
There is going to be a lot of liquidity resting in both the high and the low
And so for example when a new session starts
You can see London session for example
Once it sweeps Asia highs
It'll typically get a reaction and then trade to maybe Asia lows
Same thing will apply once you're trading New York session
You want to be looking out for these highs and lows
So very often when we're trading New York session
We're looking to target maybe London highs or maybe London lows as our external liquidity
Why? Because there is a lot of liquidity resting in both those highs and lows
Okay, so the indicator I have here is ICT kill zones and pivot
So this marks out these sessions that we have
For example here we have Asia session and we have London session
And this shows us our Asia session high and also the Asia session low
This is the lowest point at which Asia session has traded to
And this is the highest point
And at these two levels there are going to be a lot of liquidity resting there
A lot of stop losses resting there
Just think about this logically
If someone's taking for example a short during Asia session
They're most likely putting their stop loss at that Asia session high
Or if they're taking a long at that Asia session low
Considering that these are both incredibly prominent liquidity pools
What can you expect when previous session trades to either these high or these lows
You're going to expect rejection
Now let's look at London session
Let's see what happens here
As you can see during London session
We went ahead and ran up to Asia highs
After we swept Asia highs
What happened?
We got displacement lower and then we ran to London lows
And as you guys have heard us say before
Price is always doing one of two things
It's either rebalancing ranges or it is seeking liquidity
In the case of session highs and lows
It will typically run from one session high to another session low
Or from one session low to another session high
Understanding the importance of previous session highs and lows
Is going to help you determine your bias every single day
So if we're going into New York session
And we see that London highs has been swept
We can expect price to now trade to London session lows
And you're also probably wondering
What are these other sessions on the chart
So for example
If I'm trading during New York PM session
There's going to be resting liquidity
At what?
The previous session right?
So lunch hour or New York AM session
We went over these sessions guys in the last video
So if you need to look back at that
To see what times these sessions are happening at
Go look back at that other video
But as you can see here
Asia session lows
That's a draw on liquidity
Asia session highs
And your goal as a trader
Is to always find the next draw on liquidity
If you're trading London session for example
On this day
And you see okay
We just took out Asia session highs
We could potentially be looking for shorts to wear now
Asia session lows
That's how price is going to play out most of the time right?
We sweep Asian highs
London session trades to Asia session lows
Now let's look at New York session for example
After New York session is done
What do we create?
We create these extreme lows
And these extreme highs
This is New York session AM high
New York session AM low
What happens here?
Price takes out New York session AM low
And then runs to New York AM session high
The only thing you really need to be taking out of this
Is that you always want to be referring to previous session highs and lows
To find the next draw on liquidity
Alright guys
Once again
Just to emphasize how these draw on liquidity works
You can think about it like this
Let's say you have Asia session here
London session here
And now we're currently in New York AM session
If we're trading New York AM session
And we see that price
During New York AM session runs to London lows
And now this extreme low from London session has been swept
We can now anticipate
That there will be rejection at this level
If other confluences are in line of course
And look to see if longs
Will present themselves towards where?
London session highs right?
And guys note that this doesn't always need to happen
Just because if we sweep one of the highs or the lows
Of that session
Does not mean that we need to trade back
To the other side of the range
But it is typical of price
And you can't expect that reaction to happen
Like Patrick was saying
If we start getting that structure higher
Or if we start getting that structure lower
And actually breaking through this low
Then we can expect this high just not to get traded back to
Yeah so like Blake was saying
If you notice that during New York AM session
We go ahead and displace through London lows
And we're not getting a reaction out of it
What can you expect?
Well you can probably expect price to continue
Trading lower during New York AM session
Rather than trading back to a previous session high
So truly the importance of all this
Is that if you understand
How strong these liquidity pools are
In these previous session highs and lows
You can identify whether or not price wants to react from them
And reverse or continue in that direction
Alright guys so the next major draw on liquidity
That we have is going to be
Previous day high and previous day low
You can also see this getting referred to as
PDH or PDL
Now how you actually find these draws on liquidity
Is just by going on the daily candle right here
So if you just go to your timeframes
If you click on the daily candle
This previous day low candle and this previous day high candle
Is all going to be draws on liquidity
Alright so looking at this range right here guys
We can mark out our previous day high and previous day low
So this is the candle from yesterday right here
This is previous day high
And then this is our previous day low
And as you can see right here guys
The previous day high is just the highest point
In which price has traded to
For that day
And the previous day low is the lowest point
In which price has traded to for that day
It's going to be a very high probability draw on liquidity
When you're going into the next day
Because at the end of the day this is going to help you
Find your daily bias
Where the daily candle is actually expanding towards
And as you can see here guys we ended up forming
Some bullish structure towards this previous day high
We ended up taking it out and then displacing back lower
And I want you guys to remember
That liquidity pools can not only be areas
Where you want price to go to
But also where areas that price can react
Off of and trade the opposite direction from
So for example here
You could be taking longs towards this draw on liquidity
Because we are in this bullish structure
But then after that once we get that reaction
Off of that liquidity pool we start forming
Structure to validate a bearish bias right
Then shorts could be valid
A good practice to have every single morning
Just going into your trading session would be
To mark out something like previous day high and previous day low
So you know the range that you are trading within
Previous day high and previous day low is going to serve
As an external liquidity point right
These are never going to be your first TPs
Previous session highs and previous session lows
Previous day highs and previous day lows
These shouldn't be your first TPs
A general rule of thumb is that your first TPs should be internal liquidity
Now previous day high and previous day low
Like every other liquidity pool guys
Doesn't necessarily have to get traded to right
But if you can start seeing that structure
To validate your bias towards that draw on liquidity
And we'll get into structure
Entry models later on but it's good to know
Actually just what these draws on liquidity actually are
Alright guys so for this next liquidity pool
We have low resistance liquidity
Also known as trend line liquidity
Or you'll also hear it referred to as failure swings
So this is known as trend line liquidity
Because you can usually just draw a line
And it will look like a trend line
Now trend line liquidity is important
Or LRL or failure swings
Right this is what the books teach you right
Every time you hit this line right here
These people are going long and they are placing their stop losses where
Well at these swings
This is also called a failure swing
Because it's not taking the recent low
As you can see here we make a low
We make a high, we make a higher low
We don't make a lower low we make a higher low
Then we have another high, higher low
So these are all failure swings because they are not taking that recent low
And every time this trend line
Is getting hit
There is going to be stop losses placed there
In other words if you refer back to our last liquidity video
We went over buy side liquidity and sell side liquidity
So if we are generating
Low resistance liquidity in bullish order flow
What are we generating
We are generating a bunch of sell side liquidity
Right
We have price continuing to run higher
But failing to take out the previous low
So what do we have amongst all these lows
More sell side liquidity
And so when you have all this sell side liquidity
Just bunched up together
That creates low resistance liquidity
Same applies for a bearish sense right
If we are trending bearish
We can mark out this trend line liquidity
Then we can see here that amongst all these
Failure swings
We have what, buy side liquidity
And so we have a bunch of buy side
Being generated amongst this trend line
Therefore creating low resistance liquidity
So now let's actually look at this on the chart
Alright guys as you can see right here
We have bullish trend line liquidity
Bullish low resistance liquidity
Now why is this low resistance liquidity
Because there are failure swings being made
At every single swing point
Meaning that every time we make a swing high
Every swing high is not taking that previous swing high
So we just keep making these lower highs
So as you can see here we have a swing high
There's stop losses being rested here
We have another swing high, stop losses being rested here
More swing highs, stop losses are being rested here
And these stop losses aren't getting taken
Right, so they just keep getting generated
Keep getting generated
This is also known as generated liquidity
You'll hear often times
And then eventually the market likes to take out these
Stop losses usually really fast
We usually see super fast movement
Through all of these swing highs
Through all of these stop losses
And that's exactly what the market does right here
So in really simple words
Just look for bunched up highs or bunched up lows
That's going to be your low resistance liquidity
If we pair this with a little bit of previous concepts here
You can see that before price ran this low resistance liquidity
We went ahead and swept some sell side
We react off that sell side
And then price goes ahead and rips through all this LR
And typically it will run through all the LR
Rather than just the first swing high
And that is something you should really know
Because low resistance liquidity in general
Is a pretty obvious draw on liquidity
Especially on the lower timeframes
So definitely make sure you can understand
The concept of low resistance liquidity
Because if you're able to spot it
You're going to be able to take trades targeting the low resistance liquidity
Just think about it like a bunch of stop losses
Ready to get ran through
Alright now we'll show an example of what bearish low resistance liquidity looks like
Alright now here's an example of bearish low resistance liquidity
Now this is trendline liquidity
Because every time we make that swing low
The next swing low is not taking that previous swing low
And it's just making a higher low
As you can see here we have a swing low
Then we have that higher low
Another swing low, we have another higher low
And we have another higher low
And these are all just stop losses ready to get ran
We have stop losses here
We have stop losses here, here, here, here
We have a bunch of bunched up sell side liquidity
Using some previous concepts right
We reject off of this bearish for rally
Got to the left of us
And then all these lows end up getting ran through
So yeah being able to spot this guys
This is going to help you a lot also
Just with bias in general
If you can see where the low resistance liquidity
Is being generated
Then that is most likely where the market is going to be drawing towards
Alright guys so next up we have
Equal highs and equal lows
Mark this out using EQH and EQL
So equal highs and equal lows
Are going to be highs and lows printed
At the same exact price point
So as you can see here
This candle's high is printed exactly
At what? 27201.0
And then the high right next to it
Is printed exactly at 27201
And on the right of us you can see that these are not
Equal highs, why? Because it's not printed
At the exact same price point
And equal lows same thing and also it doesn't matter guys
What candle color it is
This can be a green candle, this can be a red candle
These equal lows are printed also at the exact same price point
And these are not equal lows because these are not printed
At the exact same price point
Let's just get into some now chart examples
Now very similarly to the last concept
About trend line liquidity
The books often teach you to be
Longing when there's a bullish trend line
And to be shorting when there's like this bearish trend line
And that's not always the case
And that's not really how we're going to be trading
Because we trade ICD concepts right?
And equal highs, the books teach you that
This is an area of resistance
And that you should short this
And where are people going to be putting those stop losses?
Well at that resistance level right? At those equal highs
So there's going to be a lot of liquidity generating there
And same thing for the equal lows
Well people are going to be longing this area
Why? Because they see it as support
They see this bouncing off the same price point again
And they're going to be like
Oh this is a great area to go long
And then they're going to be putting their stop losses there
And then this is just a great liquidity pool for us
Smart money traders to be targeting
You'll see them getting made on both NQ
And also ES
But what should you actually be paying attention to?
Well ES, since it is a less volatile index
Not many people are trading on ES
Versus NQ
You're going to see a lot more
Equal highs and lows getting made
But then they're not actually getting taken
You're going to just see a lot more equal lows and equal highs
Getting made on ES
You don't want to be paying attention to it
Because the liquidity pools are not as prominent as NQ
Alright so as you guys see on the left here
We have NQ and on the right here
We have ES
Now NQ is going to be having a lot less
Of these equal highs and equal lows
Versus ES has a lot more of these
Equal highs and lows
Now this is just because there's more volatility
On NQ versus ES
Right?
So you do not want to be paying attention to these
Equal highs and lows on ES
This is going to be messing you up
And because we're trading on NQ
This is actually what you should be focusing on
Now this indicator I use guys is just
Equal highs and lows by Jay Zester
So this just marks out all of the
Equal highs and lows that are being made
Even when they're spread apart like this
And just to sort of play off what Blake was saying
The reason there's so many equal highs and equal lows
In comparison to ES, the S&P 500 futures charts
Is because they are created due to
The lack of volatility
In comparison to NQ where equal highs and equal lows
Are an actual generation of
Liquidity rather than just a result
Of low volatility if that makes sense
So when they're created on
NQ and ES you can anticipate
Those to be way more prominent liquidity pools
You can expect price to trade to those levels
To react from those levels in comparison to ES
Where they're just really another
Swing high or swing low or another
Random set of equal highs and equal lows
Don't refer to equal highs and equal lows on ES
Make sure you're trying to spot them on NQ
And start noticing how price
Reacts at those levels
So you can obviously see that there's times
Where you will have equal lows or equal highs
That are practically one or two
Three candles apart, for example right here
You have equal lows and then there's
Times where you have equal highs that
Are two swings apart, right?
So you have a swing high right here and a swing high
Right here. These swing highs
And swing lows when they're two
Separate trading legs and
Separate swings apart
They're going to hold more power than something like
A pair of equal lows that are
Backed by two consistent candles or something
Like that. So anytime you
Do identify equal highs
Or equal lows that are created from two
Major swings, just know that that's going to
Hold a lot more power as a liquidity pool
In general. Alright guys next up we have
Data wicks. These are going to be your data lows
And your data highs. Now what actually is a
Data wick? Well a data wick occurs
When there is news. Now remember guys
When we were talking about time in the last video
Where we brought up Forex Factory. So Forex Factory
Again guys is going to be telling you when this
High impact news is occurring. So you'll most
Likely be seeing these data wicks
Happen during high impact
Red folder news. This is going to be typically
At times like 8.30am,
10am, yeah FOMC
At 2 and 2.30pm. And really
Just any other red folder news event
That you can find on a website like Forex Factory
Or whatever other news
News event website you use
But just know that anytime
These high impact news are released
There's typically going to be one incredibly
Volatile candle in the market
Which is going to create a data high
And it's going to create a data low. And obviously
As you can see in this illustration here
That high and low is going to serve as what?
A very prominent liquidity pool. So you'll
See price typically do stuff
Like this. Where news will drop. Let's say it's
Like an 8.30 CPI. After CPI drops
Price will trade to the CPI high
The data high. It will sweep it
And then react and then maybe trade to the data low
This is actually a super
Super common occurrence that you'll see with
Data wicks and
Actually will serve as a great confluence
When it comes to the inversion model which we'll get
Into later in the future. But
Get in the habit of marking out
Data highs and data lows anytime
Red folder news drops
Because those are really, really, really
Important levels. Now the reason these data wicks
Are actually draws on liquidity is because these
Are seen as imbalances in the market
These huge wicks are imbalances
Because there's not orders getting filled
Here, right? So price needs to trade
Back towards these prominent wicks
And again they're going to be very, very obvious
Price will typically fill orders here
Or seek liquidity here. Now this might be
Like a stupid thing to say, but if
You ever do see a random candle that's
Not a news event create two
Crazy volatile
Wicks. Don't just mark that as data highs
And data lows. Make sure it is actually
A news event that is creating these wicks
If not, you're simply not going to be marking out
Data highs and data lows and it might confuse you
Alright guys, so on this day, this was
Friday, March 7th. If we go over
To Forex Factory right here, we see
That there is NFP, right? So this is
Non-farm employment change
This is a red folder high impact news event
And as you can see here, in the next candle
That drops, we have an extremely
Volatile candle that takes out a lot
Of buy side, a lot of sell side liquidity. It's a
Huge, huge candle of around
This was around 200 points this day and it
Creates this data high and this data low
Now like what Patrick was saying, when you see
These highs and lows being made, you can
Wait for one of these ranges to be taken
To then target the opposing range
So for example here, we end up taking out this
Data high, we end up trading lower, we have
A bearish for value gap, which eventually
Delivers us to this data low
So really, like I was saying, all you gotta take
Away from this, anytime you have those high impact news
Days, just mark out that candle
As you can see here, immediately after
8.30, which was a news candle, you have 8.31
Sweep that data high and then you start getting
Displacement lower towards data lows. Honestly
My best advice to you guys is
That when you have days like this where you have
High impact news, really try to identify
These levels and wait for
Price to take out one of these highs
Or lows, whether it is the data highs first or the
Data lows first and then look to see
If there are entry opportunities
Towards the level that hasn't been taken out
Yet, right? In this case, you had the sweep of data highs
First, so now you can anticipate, okay, maybe
We can find shorts to data lows. Regarding
Your entry, we're gonna elaborate on that more
In future videos, but for now
Just focus on always
Marking out these data highs and data lows
Anytime on these high impact news days
Okay, so next up here, guys, we have is unfilled
For value gaps. You also hear this being
Referred to as your internal range liquidity
Your IRL, and this is just how the market
Moves. We move from internal range liquidity
To external range liquidity, and external
Range liquidity is just those buy side
And sell side, those major swing highs
Those major swing lows. We went over that
In our first video, right? Discussing
Liquidity part one
And this is how we get to those external
Range liquidity pools by this internal
Range liquidity or these unfilled for value
Gaps. So oftentimes what you'll see the market
Do is we'll have this being
Our external range liquidity right here. The market
Will then trade towards this internal
Range liquidity being this unfilled
For value gap. This is an imbalance
In the market, right? Same thing like the
Data wicks where we want to fill orders
The market likes to fill orders at
This internal range liquidity at these for value
Gaps. And then once we trade into this, this is
Your internal range liquidity and then we trade
To that external range liquidity, right? And
This keeps happening where we keep trading
Into internal range liquidity to external
Until we obviously have a shift
In structure. And for a bearish sense here
We're trading with this external range liquidity
We then trade higher into
This bearish for value gap which is that
Internal range liquidity to then trade back
Lower to the external range liquidity. Okay
Guys, now let's get into some examples of
This. Okay guys, so as you can see here we have
A bunch of these bullish for value gaps here
That are unfilled. So this is that imbalance
Right? This is that internal range liquidity
And then above here we have our external range
Liquidity here and we also have some
Buyside liquidity right here. So typically what you'll
See the market do after we take out
Buyside liquidity is for then price
To rebalance towards this internal range
Liquidity, right? So we can mark this out as our
ERL. This is your external range.
This is also your external range but since we are
Bullish, right? And we are creating these bullish
For value gaps, you can expect this to trade towards
That buyside external range liquidity. Price
Then trades into these imbalances
And then trades towards this external range
Liquidity. And then again we create
More unfilled bullish for value gaps. We have
One right here. We can then mark out our
External range liquidity. Price then trades
Into this for value gap. We seek out that
Liquidity and we will keep doing this until
We have a shift in structure, right? We keep
Trading to these for value gaps. We then have another
Unfilled bullish five minute for value gap right here.
We then mark out our external range liquidity.
This is our internal range liquidity. We trade
Into this for value gap and that delivers us
Towards this external range liquidity. So this is simply
Just how the market moves, guys. Through these unfilled
For value gaps and through this buyside and
Sellside external range liquidity. And this will
Keep happening until we have that shift
In structure, that market structure shift.
And if you think back to our first liquidity video where
I was just talking about, you know, bullish structure
And bearish structure where in bullish structure
You're generating lots of sellside, bearish structure
You're generating lots of buyside, right?
And in order to maintain bullish
Order flow or bearish order flow, you need to be trading
Back towards this internal liquidity, right?
So if we were to draw this out with simply
Just a strong tool, bullish price action
Is going to look like this. It's going to move up.
It's going to create that higher low
Every single time and higher high.
And every single time that it's doing this, what are
You also doing? You're trading back
Towards this internal liquidity, these unfilled
Gaps that's delivering price higher.
Same is going to apply vice versa
In a bearish sense. So this is just
Good to know because anytime, for example,
You want to take a long and bullish
Order flow, you want to wait for price to hit
That internal liquidity before you execute
A long and take a trade higher, right?
You don't want to be longing at these
Peaks. You want to wait for price to trade
Back towards that internal liquidity and then you
Can target that external liquidity. Alright guys
And finally, for the last liquidity
Pool, we have the devil's mark.
This is also known as just a
Wickless candle, a candle without a wick.
So typically, every single candle you guys
See will have a wick on the top and have a wick
On the bottom. With the devil's mark, the candle
Fails to print a wick. And for this example,
We fail to print that open high
That you typically see with a bullish
Candle and we just print an open low.
For example, here in the bearish sense, we fail to
Print that open low and we just create
That open high. And this is
Actually just an imbalance in price. So what
Price typically likes to do is
Trade away from this and then add that
Wick later on. You really want to focus on
Devil's marks just on the higher time frame because
Typically with lower time frame candles,
You can see that, you know, it is common
For price to fail to create
A wick. But it's not going to be as
Prominent as like a liquidity pool as it would
Be on the higher time frame, right? If you have an
Hourly candle fail to make a wick, then
You can expect price at one point
To trade back to that level and correct
That imbalance in price. Now again guys, the
Reasoning this is just so important is because
You will rarely see candles without
Wicks. Like pretty much every single candle
Here you'll see has a wick, has a wick, has a wick, has a wick.
But what do we even notice about this candle
Right here, right? This is that 11 o'clock candle.
So this is an hourly candle. So as you can see
With this hourly candle, we create an
Open low, but there's no
High. You can mark this out as your 11
O'clock Devil's mark. And again like what Patrick
Was saying, you want to be focusing on this for like
The hourly time frame. 30 minute maybe, 15
Minute, 4 hour. But usually that
Higher time frame is going to be a higher probability
Liquidity pool. So here 11 o'clock
Opens, we fail to print the open
High. We end up trading away from it.
And then price trades towards that Devil's mark
Printing the wick on this
Wickless candle. And I don't know
Why it's called Devil's mark. Don't ask
Me. I don't know why any of these
Like I don't know. I don't know why it's called Devil's mark
Actually don't ask me. I don't know
Why a lot of these things have fucking weird ass
Names, but it's called a Wickless candle.
Just know they work. Just know they work
Please. But I do want to emphasize
Like all this works only
When you pair it with all the other confluences
We've taught you, right? You're not just going to take along
Because you see this Devil's mark get printed
Obviously that makes no sense
What do you want to wait for? You most likely want to
Wait for in this case to have like a sell side
Sweep and then present maybe a long opportunity
Towards that 11 a.m. Devil's mark.
So as you can see here, price eventually
Delivers lower. It takes out this sell side
And then you get that delivery up to the Devil's mark
Of course with more confluences
Here you can see Fair Valley gods are getting created
That are getting respected and then delivering price to that
11 a.m. Devil's mark. I say it in every single video
But you never use these concepts individually
You try to pair them with other things
That's how you create these strategies that deliver
Towards these liquidity pools, towards these imbalance ranges
Alright, so now let's pair some of this shit together
So imagine this is a current
Price action you're looking at
You see New York AM session deliver to what?
Let's say this is London lows
Price sweeps London lows and then you identify
Oh damn, we got some
Low resistance liquidity above
We have a nice buy side level above
Right here. This buy side level
Also has an unfilled gap
And on top of that we have equal highs
At this level. Oh my god, this is an amazing
Opportunity to long. We took out London lows, we have LR above
Buy side above, unfilled gap, equal highs
Bang, there you go. Now you're using your
Fucking brain. You're putting all this
Shit together. You realize we swept
London lows, we have all this generated buy side above
This is a great chance to
Long. And that's when you'll truly see these
Concepts work. If we're in bearish order
Flow, but we finally hit some sort of bullish
Pedia rate, we sweep some sell side liquidity
Now we can look for longs because we know
There's actually a reason for price
To deliver in this direction, right? There's imbalances
In price, there's liquidity being generated
This needs to get taken
Or at least should get taken most of the time. Therefore
You know long opportunities
Are very viable in this
Scenario. So what do you wait for? You wait for anything
To validate longs in this sense, right?
Let's say we end up opening a
Bullish for value gap here. We tap into this
Five minute bullish for value gap. We see it
Getting respected. Awesome
Great. Now let's smack some fucking
Longs, take this LR, take this buy side
Equal highs, fucking 10 TPs
And we got a damn Bugatti. And you can
Expect price to go to all
Of this, maybe edge those
Equal highs and then stop you out. And I'm kidding
But yeah, like I said
Pair everything with everything we've
Taught you. You're slowly going to start building your
Understanding of how all these concepts work foundationally
How to use them with other stuff and
How to properly execute on the market. We know
That there's a lot of information on this video. It
Might have been a bit overwhelming, but definitely go back
Rewatch anything. Try to find it on the charts yourself
Get in the habit of marking out all these
Things and it's going to help you identify
These liquidity pools. You're going to know where
The next draw on liquidity is. Hence the
Name draw on liquidity. Where is price going to
Draw next? The only way to know where price is
Going to draw next is by being able to identify
These types of liquidity pools. Please guys
Your homework is to find some
Low resistance liquidity, find some unfilled
Gaps, some internal range liquidity, find
Some equal highs, some equal lows, find the fucking
Data high and data low, find that session liquidity
Find those London lows, those London highs, those
Asia highs, those Asia lows and
Notice how price is reacting off of them
Dude, when I first started
Trading, I would spend
Fucking hours
On the charts just tape reading
Like literally I would just sit
On my phone and look at how
Price is moving, where it's reacting off of
And it's going to help you understand
The charts, right? Sit there
Analyze, try to piece together
Confluences and you're going to understand
The narrative of price. It is a
Language. Trading is a language
And you really need to put the time in
While you're learning to be able to identify
These levels, to be able to see how they react
How they deliver price and it's going to
Make you a great trader. You're not going to become
Great overnight, right? In the beginning you're going to
Spend tons of tons of hours just
Analyzing but eventually it will
Click, it'll make sense, you'll understand
This stuff like the back of your hand and you're going to
Be able to execute with super high
Conviction and low hesitation
And catch banger trades. So yeah guys
I mean we hope you learned something from
Our liquidity part two, episode
Seven. We look forward to posting more
For you guys. We have some cool vlogs coming out as well
Look forward to that. Please subscribe if you haven't
Already. We're going to be trying to push out this bootcamp as
Much as possible. We have tons of shit going on
But we're really trying our best. We want to make
Sure this is the best series there is on YouTube
For ICT, for people who really want
To get into the markets efficiently and know
The right information. We're not going to be teaching you
Nonsense that you don't need. Everything we teach you
Is important and is applied every single
Day by both Blake and I
And this is how we've gotten to the point where we can have
High conviction biases that play out nearly every
Single day where we can have high conviction drawn
Liquidities that play out nearly all the time and have
High win rate with our trading models
That being said, thanks so much for watching
ICT for dummies
Episode seven
Liquidy part two
Alright
What's up, boys? Make sure to like
Follow
There's no following
Follow our Instagram, follow our
TikTok, follow our Twitter
That we never post on ever
Subscribe to our OnlyFans
Wow, I'm so sorry we have to
Teach you guys. It's a blessing and a curse
It is. Much love